people now finally have their hands on
the m2 macbook air that's just been
released but what if there are certain
advantages that the m2 macbook pro has
over the air other than making you feel
like you have a pro laptop just based on
the name alone well i was actually able
to find seven advantages which i'm going
to be fully focusing on in this video
because in a previous one i highlighted
the top seven problems including the
issue with the base 256 gig model
storage performance so if you want to
learn about that definitely check that
other video out but for this one we're
going to be specifically focusing on the
advantages the m2 macbook pro has over
the new air to help you make sure you're
making the right buying decision so
let's get started but first we are
launching an m2 macbook air giveaway yes
we ordered four models of the new
macbook airs and we're giving one of
them away and to join all you have to do
is subscribe to this channel and comment
on our launch week macbook air videos
including this video and we'll choose
one comment at random and announce the
winner right here on youtube on july
25th and we'll ship it to you no matter
where you are in the world for free yes
we'll cover the shipping charges the
import taxes everything so be sure to
subscribe and comment to help us reach
our goal of 1 million subscribers before
the end of this month and now let's get
into the top advantages the m2 macbook
pro has over the air now the first
advantage is of course that the m2
macbook pro does not have a notch right
on the display now some people
absolutely hate the notch they can't
stand it at all and that is what the m2
macbook air comes with even though it
doesn't have face id or anything like
that it just has a better webcam but it
has that huge notch which is a bigger
deal on a smaller 13.6 inch display than
it is on let's say the 14 or 16 inch it
looks larger and some people absolutely
hate it so if that sounds like you then
maybe the m2 macbook pro was made for
you you just get the straight bezel no
notch at all now getting into the second
advantage the fact is the m2 macbook pro
does have a fan now this does mean that
you are going to be getting better
performance for extended workloads maybe
even workloads that last 5 10 15 minutes
not even hours because in our testing we
showed that in our most extreme thermal
throttling test even this m2 macbook pro
managed to throttle and clock down the
speed of the chip all the way from
around 29.5 watts down to seven because
the fan even with the fan it wasn't able
to keep it cool it was maxing out at 7
200 rpms now that was an extreme test
but in other ones like cinebench or
lightroom photo exports we actually got
the fan to ramp up to almost 4 or even 5
000 rpms in some cases which means that
without a fan with the m2 macbook air
you're likely going to see more
throttling than this model so if you're
doing a lot of extended workloads maybe
that fan is going to be a better choice
for you and now moving on to the third
advantage the m2 macbook pro has over
the air this one actually comes with the
10 core gpu as standard so anybody going
into the apple store best buy anywhere
else and buying the base model which is
basically the only one available you're
going to be getting the faster 10 core
gpu now that is going to be great for
different things like gaming getting
more fps getting of course sustained
gaming fps with the fan installed so
that is another advantage that it comes
base with the 10 core gpu now getting
into the fourth advantage you have
better battery life of course this m2
macbook pro comes with a larger battery
than the m2 macbook air and in terms of
what apple rates the battery life to be
like it gives you two extra hours of
battery life however the m2 chip
actually comes packed with newer and
faster efficiency cores which means that
they can handle more tasks by themselves
without having to fire up the
performance cores which actually leads
to some pretty impressive battery life
on this m2 macbook pro even compared to
the previous m1 macbook pro so because
it has a larger battery it is going to
be giving you the best battery life out
of any new apple silicon macbook out
there even better than the 14 and 16
inch models and now getting into the
fifth advantage the empty macbook pro
has over the new macbook air this one of
course comes with the touch bar now i
personally don't like it but there are
some people who love the touch bar they
love using it they love customizing it
there's also the better touch tool which
allows you to really get into the fine
tuning and customization of the touch
bar that is an advantage because the
macbook air does not get the touch bar
it just has the standard function keys
which you cannot customize them so to
some people this is the last touch bar
equipped macbook pro and some are
actually going to be buying this for
that reason so if you enjoy that touch
part or you like the idea of having a
digital display on your keyboard then
this is going to be an advantage for you
with the macbook pro now for the sixth
advantage this m2 macbook pro comes
standard with the higher end 67 watt
power adapter now you might not know
this but the base m2 macbook air
actually comes with a 30 watt adapter
which is less than half the wattage or
speed of charging compared to this m2
macbook pro so it's going to be charging
slower than this one is which is very
interesting now if you want the same
charger you actually have to pay an
extra 20
on the macbook air to get the 67 watt
adapter just like this one gets so this
one definitely has the advantage of
having that built in when you buy it
standard and finally for the seventh
advantage the macbook pro has over the
air this one actually has studio quality
microphones which the m2 macbook air is
not advertised to get so
in theory this should be better now the
interesting thing is we compared the
microphones and the webcams of this m2
macbook pro to the higher end 14 inch
and surprisingly the microphone on this
m2 macbook pro sounds a little bit
better because the 14 inch is a little
bit muted and dual the 13 inch m2
macbook pro still uses the same 720p
webcam as it did for years but they did
kind of update the software a little bit
so there's more contrast there right
away you can tell that the image looks
more natural you can see more detail in
my hair and it should have better
microphones but you guys be the judge of
that and let me know down in the comment
section below so to our surprise you get
pretty good studio quality microphones
on this m2 macbook pro which you are not
getting on the macbook air so there you
guys go those were the top seven
advantages the mt macbook pro has over
the air and that's me throwing some
positivity your way because there are
some good things about this m2 macbook
pro now if you have some thoughts let me
know in the comment section below and
definitely subscribe and comment to
enter that giveaway because this video
is also included and once again on the
25th we are going to announce the winner
right here on youtube so definitely
click the circle above to subscribe and
check out one of those two videos right
over there thanks for watching and we'll
see you in the next video
[Music]
[Music]
you